I'm now joined by professor of political
science Peter Mathews who's in Long
Beach California he's the author of the
recently published book a dollar
democracy and many thanks indeed for
joining us an old world news so the
analysts are working on overdrive now to
find out the explanation for why Donald
Trump turi in the u.s. presidential
elections what do you think caused
Hillary Clinton to lose a selection well
there were several things I mentioned a
few months ago throughout the last two
months that this could be a brexit
election similar number two in other
words we're looking at lots of
dissatisfaction a lot of anger but the
fact that working middle class and
working poor people lost jobs there were
good manufacturing jobs in the heartland
in those states like Pennsylvania and
Michigan and those jobs haven't come
back the ones that came back were only
two-thirds of jobs are low paying jobs
and people who are really furious at the
establishment because of that in the
United States as they were in Britain
when they voted for brexit so I pretty
been some of that is a good possibility
of course much of us are also we thought
Hillary Clinton could do well because
she had the machine behind her she
hadn't bribed to presidents behind her
she had Bernie Sanders so it was either
way could gone either way and I believe
me the hidden vote that was the vote of
many Donald Trump supporters that were
not read into the polls is what put him
over the top and it's totally
understandable why that happened now the
question how will he govern Willie
govern in an inclusive way to bring
people together or continue to be
divisive when his rhetoric was such in
primaries where he talked about blocking
illegal immigrants from coming here and
building a wall and deporting 11 million
of them if he could just get off there a
divisive rhetoric and bring the country
together and then continue in this plans
to create jobs through infrastructure
investment he might do well but many
people are concerned about him and his
character and especially people who are
I think minorities in america are really
worried right now including some of my
own friends which is a shame that we
have to even worry about that I'm not so
concerned because I know the United
States have the checks and balance
system and the president has to have
Congress with him to do a lot of things
and they can actually end up removing
him because the wrong thing in professor
Matthews I mean America is now deeply
divided it's not just across the states
or the red
lines and the blue lines their divisions
with religion ethnicity race and gender
say will you be able to heal the wounds
to bring people together see promised in
his victory speech yes his victory
speech was very inclusive and very kind
in a way he also praised the repent for
being a worthy opponent I think if he
sticks to the issues of rebuilding the
economy bringing those jobs bat and
being inclusive and also investing in
infrastructure and you know changing the
foreign policy of United States to some
extent to turn more toward the people
here and to accommodate other countries
to certain extent to working with Russia
for example as a partner to smash Isis
and to not be so harsh on Russia and
start a new Cold War he's the things
that we went too far with beginning a
new cold war after the Soviet
disappeared if he could do those things
then people will see him as a successful
leader but he's only got a couple of
years to do it because right now it's
got the Republican Senate and the house
and there's the best opportunity to try
to go forward in a positive way
inclusive way in unite the country so
will he be able to deliver on the
promises that we heard during this
election campaign over the course of the
last year or so namely the building of a
war between the United States and Mexico
for example no I don't think he'll be
able to run at Walt's gonna cost dozens
of billions of dollars first of all
physically speaking and secondly he
wouldn't really need to do that because
if he can renegotiate the trade
agreements with on NAFTA it'll help to
balance out the trailer in two countries
and create more middle-class jobs in
Mexico and the United States which will
then keep many undocumented workers and
having to come across the wall in the
first place so fair trade as opposed to
free trade that's what he should be
talking about he's talked about it a
little bit in the campaign so he needs
to implement those policies he won't
even need a wall and it's going to be
virtually impossible to build one for
that kind of cost and to deport 11
million undocumented people it's
impossible I don't think he's gonna
focus on that too much right now that
was an electron while I believe ok
professor pizza Matthews a professor for
political science many thanks for
joining us and sharing you all your
insight into this my pleasure thank you
so much